karl marx never before had a philosopher
and never again had such a great impact as
karl marx revolutionary parties
governments relied on him
whole societies were revolutionary
changed in his name in
countries as different as russia
china vietnam cuba nicaragua must be at the peak
but also in others  states there were
revolutions until finally almost a
third of the entire human population if you count
china lived under communism
about 100 years after the death of marx the
communist world that had come into being went down again after
the fall of the iron curtain many people said
marx had himself  wrong and
capitalism is ultimately the more
promising economic system
one hoped to reconcile democracy market economy
and the fair distribution of
wealth
but we do not know values this optimism fo
long the major e
onomic crises have shaken beli
f in the market economy and it shows  t it is becoming increasingly
clear that capitalism has precisely
the structural weaknesses
that marx carefully described in his main
work
, capital
on capitalism is
therefore undoubtedly more topical than ever no
question marx still has a lot to
say
to us in the book i also try to present the
philosophy of history the basis superstructure
theory the criticism of religion and of
course his
analyzes on added value accumulation impoverishment from capital
cleanly and clearly, yes on
At the end of the day, of course, we have to
ask what use this discovery
is for us today